[Music]
he said he would be there for the people
of Florida as it takes to rebuild that
is what we're doing today
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
51 million dollars to policyholders
[Music]
families when it comes to the choice
between the vision he and Congressional
Democrats share for the middle class and
the extreme
inflation worsening agenda of
congressional Republicans could not be
higher independent economists are
warning that republicans in Congress
want to worsen inflation with deficit
exploding tax giveaways for the rich and
big corporations
but that's not all
Congressional Republicans from Senator
Rick Scott to Senator Ron Johnson to the
Republican study committee which
includes most House Republicans have all
been unmistakenly clear that they want
to put Medicare and Social Security on
The Chopping Block
yesterday on Meet the Press Senator
Scott was yet again forced to answer for
the extreme proposal he released earlier
this year that would force Medicare to
expire in five years unless Congress
voted to renew it
he tried to snake his way out of this
plan by by throwing up a debunked lie
attacking the new Power we gave Medicare
to negotiate lower drug costs for which
he was called out on the facts
now
let that sink in for a second let that
sink in for just a second a member of
Republican Senate leadership proposes
that Medicare expires in five years and
defends himself with a made-up excuse to
strip Medicare of its power to hold big
farmers feet to the fire and lower drug
costs for families
[Laughter]
and here's the kicker in the private
sector Rick Scott oversaw the biggest
Medicare fraud in history so don't take
my word for it don't take our word for
it
let's take politifacts so with that you
know you really can't make things up RX
kick us off thanks uh Karine um I wonder
if the White House has any response to a
Ally of Vladimir Putin saying that he he
was involved in election meddling and if
there are concerns here at the White
House or does White House has assurances
for the American people that the
elections that are underway right now
they'll include tomorrow uh we'll be
free and fair of of any uh foreign
interference so a couple of things that
we want to lay out here because that's a
very important question that you just
asked Lee so with respect to any ongoing
attempts by Russian actors to influence
U.S election so I'm going to refer you
to the office of the Director of
National Intelligence these comments
though I'll say this do not tell us
anything new or surprising as we all
know it's well known and well documented
in the public domain that entities
associated with Jeff ghani and jivgani
pre-govjin have sought to influence
elections around the world including the
United States the U.S has worked to
expose and counter Russia's malign
influence efforts as we discover them so
jivgani is a known bad actor who has
been sanctioned by the United States the
United Kingdom and also the European
Union we also know that part of Russia's
efforts includes promoting narratives
aimed at undermining democracy and
sowing Division and Discord it's not
surprising that Russia would be
highlighting their attempted efforts and
fabric fabricating a story about their
successes on the eve of an election but
to your question you know of what we are
doing I've spoken to the pope at the
podium about this quite a bit about the
administration's effort to protect the
security and resilience of our elections
and to safeguard our election
infrastructure including by combating
malicious efforts by Foreign adversaries
to uh to spread these this information
that work began before this
Administration and has continued under
the Biden Harris Administration as well
but specifically actions we have taken
to counter these types of malign
influence include sanctions as you all
know we've been announce them from here
travel bans as well exposure information
sharing foreign investment screening
anti-money laundering and expulsions so
we have also worked with our fellow
democracies to expose and counter the
counter foreign malign influence abroad
as well so uh but any specifics to uh to
this uh to this new revelation I would
refer you to dni specifically to the
question of what does white has a
message to people who are casting their
ballots now earlier tomorrow in person
that their votes will be tabulated
accurately and fairly in light of these
comments or should people have
confidence in their election systems
people should have confidence in their
election system as we have said many
times before
having the right to vote is the most
sacred uh right and people should really
exercise that right and and they should
feel safe in their uh in their in their
election process
Israeli media is reporting for
presidents with incoming Israeli or
likely incoming prime minister of Israel
Benjamin the other today can you confirm
that you have a readout of the
discussion yes I I confirmed that we'll
have
in a
oh yes yes uh this is I'm confirming a
call with uh with the president had with
Benjamin Netanyahu so yes the president
did speak with him today so confirming
it that right now uh to congrat
congratulate him on his party's Victory
and command Israel's free and fair
elections the president reaffirmed the
strength of the bilateral partnership
and underscored his unwavering support
for israeli's security we will continue
to closely monitor the government
formation process as you know that is
the next process in this we we look
forward to continuing to work with the
Israeli government on our shared
interests and values we will have a more
full uh Fuller readout for all of you as
we normally do
it's just some housekeeping to start can
you give us a sense of what the
president will be doing tomorrow on
Election Day tomorrow night and if he
has any plans to make an address on
Wednesday after the results so a couple
of things there I'll lay out for two for
you all tomorrow and also on Tuesday so
tomorrow and Tuesday the president will
have a full schedule here at the White
House
as I previously said we expect the
president will address the elections the
day afterwards and when we have details
on the timing of that we of course will
share it with all of you but as but I
also just want to know as you all know
because you guys have covered this these
past couple of years in 2022 it took two
weeks to to call every state in modern
elections more and more ballots are
being cast in early voting and also by
mail and many states don't start
counting those ballots until after the
ballots uh after pardon me after the
polls close on November 8th so you heard
the president say this the other night
he has been very clear on this as well
we may not know all but winners of
Elections for a few days it takes time
to count all legitimate ballots in a
legal and orderly manner that's how
that's how this is supposed to work and
it's important for us to all be patient
when wild votes are are being counted
this is not just for all of you but this
is also for the folks who are watching
and so I think it's important to just
remind folks that's something that
people should be mindful of as well
Republican leader McCarthy is clearly
expecting that the GOP will take the
house is this White House prepared to
work with the Republican Congress so I'm
not gonna I'm not gonna get into
hypotheticals I'm not going to get ahead
of what is uh you know what is going to
happen tomorrow I'm just going to you
guys will hear directly from the
president as I've stated many times
before on Wednesday the day after the
elections but I'm not going to get into
speculation from here
in the closing weeks the Recycled the
president and the supporters talked
about the ramifications of a republican
controlled Congress talking about the
choice not a referendum as the President
says
why is the president in addition to
running on his achievements not run on a
specific agenda as far as I can tell
there's only one bill the president has
said he would sign Democrats control of
the past Economist and that's a bill
[ __ ] by abortion rights why not lay out
for the public what would happen if
Democrats held both the houses so I you
know I I hear the question that you're
asking but I disagree uh in kind of the
premise of the question and what I mean
by that is if you look at the last 20
months of this Administration and I want
to be really always be careful about
elections here talking about that from
here
um the the Congressional Democrats and
also the president has delivered and
that's why we've laid out what what we
our agenda and our agenda has been to
make sure that the American people get a
little bit breathing room to make sure
that we have an economy that works for
everyone and we've laid out uh what one
of our the president's uh most biggest
priority right his economic economic
priority was making sure that we lower
costs that's what the inflation
reduction Act was so important only
Democrats voted for it if you think
about when the president walked into
into this Administration the American
Rescue plan meeting the moment that we
were currently dealing with we're
dealing with a pandemic that had shut
down small businesses hundreds of
thousands small businesses across the
country you know thousands of people
sadly were dying we had schools that
were you know that were shut down and
the president met that moment and also
to make sure that communities were
protecting were able to protect
themselves right local governments were
able to protect communities by having
being able to fund for police officers
and bring back teachers all of those
things are what we are been very proud
of making sure that we lay out that
agenda and what we have said is that we
are going to continue to make sure that
we're lowering costs we're going to make
sure that we continue to make sure that
we bring a little bit more breathing
room for the American people and let's
not forget student loan eight as well
which is going to help almost 40 million
people to give them a little bit
breathing room as well but I guess my
question is why not a specific package
why not say to the country this is what
you'll get if you elect Democrats but
why not just tell the country what we
have done why not just lay that out
which we have we have laid out what's
what's at stake we have said there is a
choice for the American people we have
been very very clear you have all
followed the president he has he has
been across the country talking
specifically how Democrats will move
forward Congressional Democrats will
move forward in delivering for the
American people when you think about
inflation when you think about what the
president has done to lower cost you
think about gas prices taking really
historical actions to make sure we tap
into tapping into the Strategic
petroleum Reserve so that we can bring
gas prices down they have by a buck 25
and you think about the inflation
reduction act which is so important
which is going to lower energy costs
which is going to lower health care
premiums Republicans this first thing
that Congressional Republicans said that
they're going to do is they're going to
repeal that and then cut you know
Medicare and Social Security we're
saying we're not going to do that the
president has been very clear we're
going to continue to fight for Medicare
we're going to continue to fight for
people's Social Security and we're going
to continue to lower cost several
questions last week John Kirby was asked
whether uh the way he was asked whether
there was efforts to get a president XI
meeting on the books of President Biden
next week where are those efforts now
and is a meeting locked in place well as
you know both sides of ours our side and
president G side staff were were asked
to figure out how we can move forward
with the meeting don't have anything to
share at this time
election interference
um and but also just the prospect of
potential violence so what are you doing
here at the White House or within the
Biden Administration to ensure that
there's not a repeated
on January 6th and to what extent should
Americans gird for conflict in and
around contested heavily contested
districts the president has said there's
300 um
Republicans running for office that have
already said they've broken test they
won't accept the results so I mean how
likely is the prospect of some kind of
violence so a couple of things because
there are kind of two questions that you
just asked there
um Andrea so law enforcement has briefed
us that there are no specific credible
threats identified at this point the
president has been briefed on the threat
on the threat environment and directed
that all appropriate steps be taken to
ensure safe and secure voting is it
occurs right in this process but I want
to be clear Americans should feel safe
going to the polls it is important for
for Americans to to do so the
Administration has taken the issue of
threats to the safety of Voters and
election officials seriously from from
day one the federal government has been
working alongside state and local
election officials in law enforcement to
take the necessary steps to keep people
safe so that will continue as far as
election deniers I think that was the
question that you were asking me uh you
know there are there are election
officials in every every state with
responsibility to ensure the candidate
who won the most votes is ultimately
sworn into office so as the president
has said you heard him say this last
week in his speech and and many times
before you can't love your country only
when you win and so it remains important
to the president and you know to State
strongly and unequivocally that violence
has no place in our democracy he will
continue to condemn violence as you've
heard him say as you've heard me say
from this very Podium he believes other
leaders of both parties have a
responsibility to communicate just that
and all Americans must unite to stand up
for American democracy and our values
and our ideals
foreign
I would need to connect with our team I
don't have anything to share at this
time and then just on the agenda the
question that she put to you about going
forward so at the beginning of this
Administration you talked a lot about
the care economy and about some of the
other items on the agenda that have not
that have fallen out of the legislation
that was enacted
um if Republicans do win both houses in
Congress are there actions that you can
take to pursue that agenda even through
executive action I'm thinking about
Universal Pre-K those kind of so I again
don't want to get into hypotheticals
here
but what I will say the president has
always said his care agenda is a
priority to him that he will continue to
work on throughout his administration I
don't have a view vehicle in which he
will choose to do that but clearly those
those are because he introduced it
because he talked about it very early on
in his administration clearly those are
our items and also during the campaign
those are policies that are and he
believes are important to the American
people to give them again a little bit
more of a breathing room but he will
continue to fight for
okay
um we don't have to get a very lengthy
Saturday statement from you clarifying
the president's remarks from the day of
Prior can you walk through what the
Genesis of that was and whether or not
you're going to stop it perhaps it would
be politically problematic had those
statements been all understand so we
just wanted to be uh you're talking
about the the
so we just wanted to be very clear on
that which is why we put out a statement
it seemed like there was uh some
confusion on that and so uh but you know
I want to say this it was some of you
were there it was uh it was loud and
hard to hear I think or maybe not
exactly what
uh What uh what was being said but I
currently don't want to get into
punditry from here and and why we did it
or do it or you know paid you know or do
it did it on TV but I spoke to to this
over the weekend the present words we
believe were Twisted
um and uh we were very clear about that
and anyone who knows Joe Biden knows he
comes from a coal a coal country from
Scranton Pennsylvania his
great-grandfather was a a mining
engineer as you all know President Biden
knows that the men and women of coal
country built this nation and he has
spent his presidency fighting for coal
communities so that they too can benefit
from the energy from the energy
transition we're in right now again the
reason why we put out uh that statement
to your you asked me about the Genesis
we believe his words were twisted and we
just wanted to make sure there was some
clarity
then um this I think this week marks the
50th Anniversary since the president's
first election in Victory oh
um
he's clearly been through a number of
these I know he's a congenital Optimist
as he likes to say but yeah can you give
a sense in your meetings with him right
now kind of what how he's feeling right
now his sense of things not not from a
political perspective hatchback
perspective but just generally In This
Moment In Time given the election but
also the Myriad of other issues that
Iran has played on you know the
president actually said this yesterday
and I think he said it a couple of times
over the weekend he is an optimist uh
and uh he believes you know he's made it
very clear about what's uh in front of
us about the choices that the American
people have uh the Stark differences
between uh what we're seeing right here
in uh in Washington DC between uh
Congressional Democrats and and also
Congressional Republicans and what we
have been able to do what he and uh and
uh Congressional Democrats have been
able to do to deliver for the American
people and so you know he believes that
going out there talking speaking
directly to the American public laying
out what he is seeing and how he sees
the future of this country uh that uh
that it's important that's why you've
seen them out there across the country
but look I think that um again he's an
optimist he has Faith he uh uh in in in
the American American values and the
American people uh he uh he believes
that um you know we can reach our best
expectations and so we should continue
to to do that and he's going to continue
to talk about that as well the way
forward and how we can get there and
make sure we just don't leave anyone
behind
great thank you so much
um I want to ask you about some of the
other comments that leader McCarthy made
over the weekend he said I'm very
supportive of Ukraine I think there has
to be accountability going forward you
always need not a blank check but to
make sure the resources are going to
where it is needed regardless of who
wins the control of the house what is
your message to Ukraine what assurances
can you give Ukraine that this
Administration
Congress will be able to continue to
provide the funding that's needed
because of course president zielinski
continues to say they need more weapons
so we are confident that the United
States support for Ukraine will be
unflinching and unwavering that's what
we believe and that's how we see this
going forward you saw Jake Sullivan say
the very same thing while he was in Kiev
on Monday and reiterated the United
States will continue to support Ukraine
across a range of areas whether it's
security assistance economic Assistance
or human rights assistance members of
Congress Republicans and Democrat have
been clear about our enduring support
for Ukraine and under any scenario to
your point to your question President
Biden is committed to work in a
bipartisan fashion as he has been he has
been doing to support Ukraine and we are
we are appreciative of the
bipartisanship that we have seen over
the last several months for Ukraine and
we're going to continue to towards that
I think you know for the ukrainians when
they hear not a blank check the message
is that that this Aid will dry up or at
least not be as forthcoming as it has
been why should they have confidence
that it will continue to be unflinching
and unwavering well because the
president has been very clear Jake
Sullivan was in Ukraine just a couple of
days ago to reiterate that very message
to president zielinski and his team we
are in regular contact as you've heard
from us with president lizinski and his
team on everything that we can do to be
helpful to them as they fight for as
they fight for their freedom again I I
understand the question but we are going
to continue to work very hard to make
sure that there is a bipartisan effort
as we continue to support Ukraine in
their efforts did you bring up Jake
Sullivan can I ask you
to respond to this reporting that he has
been engaged in confidential
conversations in recent months of top
leads to Russia Russia's President
Vladimir Putin to try to de-escalate the
crisis in Ukraine to try to make sure
that it doesn't build any direction yeah
I've seen those reportings
um so you know and look people claim a
lot of things about conversations that
we that the United States has or doesn't
have I don't have any specific
conversations to read out to you but I
do want to say a couple of things you
know we reserve the right to speak
directly at senior levels about issues
of concern to the United States
that has happened over the course of the
past a few months our conversations have
focused only on Focus only on risk
reduction in the U.S Russia relationship
we continue to adhere to our basic
principle of nothing about Ukraine
without Ukraine you've heard the
president talk about this you've heard
he's written about this in an op-ed but
we have been careful to protect the
timing and the content of the
conversation so that we have the
continuing ability to to reach Russia
and and these lines of communication are
not cut off and that's how we have moved
forward over the last several months
here and just finally created as I'm
sure you have seen there's a lot of
speculation that former president Trump
could announce he's running for
president again in 2024 in the coming
days in the coming weeks sometimes this
month how is the White House how's the
president preparing for that
announcement what type of a reaction or
response again I was asked this question
the other day
um and that's not our Focus our focus is
making sure that we lay out the choice
in front of the American people you've
heard directly from the president we're
just not is it's just what what the
former president does or doesn't do it's
not something that we are focused on
from here
but how much pressure does the President
Biden since we are now 24 hours out feel
to make that final decision about
whether he's going to run again
I'm going to say what he has said many
times and what I have said from here
many times is that the president intends
to run and I will just leave those words
there
um thanks rain on Friday the president
in his statement on the job report said
look we're going to do what it takes to
bring inflation down but as long as I'm
president I'm not going to accept an
argument that the problem is that too
many Americans are finding good jobs was
that statement directed at the Federal
Reserve which anticipates an
unemployment will go up as they raise
interest rates or if not who was the
target of that Clause absolutely not uh
that was not uh targeted at the Federal
Reserve the president has been very
clear to not interfere he will not
interfere uh in their in their
independence uh he was you know I think
speaking to the critics about uh the
number of jobs that were created and he
was very clear that you know people
should be 261
000 jobs in unemployment rate still near
historic low at 3.7 percent uh he was
trying he was laying out how the uh the
the the jobs recovery remains very
strong and so he wanted to to say that
hey look 200 sixty thousand jobs no 261
000 jobs is something that we should be
praising and we should be saying it's
it's good that people are seeing their
wages go up it's good that people are
seeing uh good paying jobs out there uh
and so I think it was more so uh to to
that certainly certainly not a message
to the Federal Reserve again we uh we
respect their independence uh and we
certainly do not interfere at any policy
decisions that they make
um I have a question about a series that
USA Today has done on super Pacs kind of
um funding School Board elections
throughout the country especially in
certain key States like Florida
um you know Michigan Maryland Texas and
some of these packs um like one called
the 1776 project pack have emphasized
opposition to lessons related to race
and social justice I guess my question
for you is have you group all like has
the White House been following this and
I guess is there any sort of concern
over the politicization of local
elections like School Board um elections
that have you know typically been
nonpartisan so look I I can't speak to
elections from here uh I I you know we
do we do try very hard in this
Administration to respect the Hatch Act
as we have been for the past several
months here and so I'm just not going to
speak to Super Pacs I'm not going to
speak to elections I'm not even going to
even Venture into uh into what the
policies are around that just to make
sure that I'm not violating uh any uh
any um any rule of law apparently
okay thank you
um I know you said from the podium a
number of times including today that the
American people will hear from the
president the day after the midterms but
a statement or remarks is not just a
departure from the Traditions that the
president has promised to restore to the
White House but it also doesn't allow
this sort of nuanced discussion about
what signal voters are sending in the
midterms or how he plans to engage with
the new Congress an outside Observer
might conclude that he doesn't want to
have a press conference because he looks
boys to lose control of one or both
Chambers so why the day before the
midterms won't the White House commit to
holding that traditional post midterms
press conference the day after the
election you've been covering this
Administration for the past 20 months
right uh as you know uh you know it
takes some time in any Administration to
lay out what the schedule is going to be
I have been very clear you're going to
hear from the president he always enjoys
taking your request questions so you
know he'll he I'm sure he'll take your
questions as well I'm just not going to
get ahead of it I'm just not going to
lay out what the what his day is going
to specifically look like on on
Wednesday but again he is going to
address the American people and I think
that's matters he's going to be clear
about what's on his mind and I'm just
not going to get ahead of it from here
president's own warning though that
democracy is on the ballot plus this
potential for unrest make it that much
more important that the president Avail
himself to the free and open press that
he has lauded as indispensable to the
functioning of democracy the president
has been very clear about where he
stands when it comes to democracy you've
heard him talk about democracy over and
over again he talked about it last week
and how important it is for the American
people as they are thinking about the
choice in front of them what's at stake
uh he's been really clear he's condemned
political violence this is a president
uh who the reason why he decided to to
run for this office was because of what
he was seeing you you know what he
talked about the soul of a Nation so I
you know disagree with your premise as
if it isn't something that is not
important to him he's made this an
important issue and again I'm not going
to get ahead of it you will you the
American people which is what matters
specifically is going to hear from the
American people
I just wouldn't follow up though
consider that our push or request to
have a press conference the day after
the midterms um on top of the others
that I know that you've heard from us
before uh but my last question would be
about Elon Musk and Twitter on a lighter
note is it an abuse for Elon Musk with
the new Twitter CEO to use the platform
to tell users to vote for republicans in
the midterms so I saw that reporting
that was earlier today right
um so
um you know I look I'm limited to what I
can say about elections from the podium
but broadly speaking I can say that
every eligible American has the right to
make their voices heard in this year's
election that is their right to do and
the president has often spoken about the
importance of voting and I'm just going
to leave it there as to not get involved
in any kind of election conversation go
ahead thanks Ken uh can you just confirm
or clarify kind of like whether the
president will be addressing the climate
Summit in Egypt and what kind of message
she will be delivering and how might it
might colored by the outcome of the
midterms that's a good let me give you a
little bit of what the trip is going to
look like so on Thursday the president
will depart for Egypt Cambodia and
Indonesia to advance U.S national
security interest and deliver for
families at home on Friday President
Biden will attend the 27th Conference of
the parties of to the U.N framework
convention on climate change cop 27 and
in Egypt he will give remarks on our
efforts to build on the unprecedented
work by the United States to reduce
emissions Advance the global climate
fight and help the most vulnerable build
resilience to climate impacts the
president will then depart for Cambodia
for the annual U.S asean Summit and the
East Asia Summit in Cambodia he will
reaffirm the United States enduring
commitment to Southeast Asia and Asian
and asean centrality building on the
success of the historic U.S asean
Special Summit in Washington D.C he will
underscore the importance of U.S Oceanic
cooperation in ensuring security and
prosperity in the region and the
well-being of our combined one billion
people and then the president will be on
his way to Indonesia to participate in
the G20 and address key challenges such
as climate change the global impact of
Putin's war on Ukraine including on
energy and on food security
affordability and a range of other
priorities important to the global
economic recovery we will have more
information on any bilats I know folks
have asked about what what violets will
occur we'll have more on that as as we
get further and further into the next
couple of days and we are also working
on having Jake Sullivan here in the
briefing room as well so he can take
your questions specifically on how how
we see the uh see this upcoming trip
okay thank you Karine the president is
campaigning in some areas that aren't
really traditional Battleground States
uh or Battleground areas I just say like
the New York suburbs Bowie Maryland why
is the president going to places where
Democrats are expected to go to do
pretty well is that because the
president expected expects his party due
fully tomorrow so
I'm going to be really cute later again
Patrick got to be really careful from
here I'm going to answer your question
but hatchback I'm going to be very
careful uh so uh but when it comes to
the president's standing uh as you were
alluding to the president's approval
weight has gone up over the last month a
few months which is very rare for the
equivalent time in any Administration if
you look at the Historical uh uh data
and his numbers track with where many of
his predecessors have been at the same
time in their presidencies including
President Obama's President Clinton and
also President Reagan so according to
some polls his numbers are above where
his predecessors was at this time as
well and his travel schedule has been on
par or similar to president President
Obama and also President Clinton so the
president has been very clear he's
talked about this you've seen him stomp
uh just you know speak to the American
people across the country and he has
talked about the economy he's talked
about what's what's at stake he's talked
about the work that he's done to deliver
for the American people he's talked
about how he's going to continue to
lower cost and he's done that for many
many different districts places and
again I don't want to get too far into
uh into uh into politics here but the
president is it thinks it's a really
really critical and important to get out
there and get in front of the American
people and that's what you saw from him
he was seeing it as most needed or why
why there without of course like you say
going into specific races but you did
mention Ron Johnson who is up for
re-election he's also he's also an
elected official who has been very clear
about what his proposal is going to be
for the American people which is putting
Medicare and Social Security on the on
the chopping box not just five years but
in each year and so we think that's
important to call out we think those are
two uh two pieces of policies or or uh
that is in critically important to the
American people so we're going to speak
against that that's something that the
president is always going to speak about
that he's going to fight for the
American people that's why you hear us
uh speaking to that look if the the
president is traveling he always says
you hear this in his speeches that he
has gotten a passport right from the
governor or passport from the mayor so
clearly uh you know it was an invite for
him to be there
really briefly to clarify something you
mentioned here at the podium you
mentioned about the president's
statement or what the president said on
Saturday regarding coal um you mentioned
a couple times or repeated a couple
times today that those words were
Twisted so who Twisted them did Mansion
twist them did someone else twist them
it's how it was reported out was being
Twisted
um so if you and I want to be really
clear because this is important if you
read the full transcript the president
was very clear commenting on a fact of
economics and Technology as it has been
from the its earliest days as an energy
superpower America is once again in the
midst of an energy transition and the
president is determined to make sure
that this transition helps all Americans
and he's been very clear about that and
these weren't some novel comments as
they were taken and twisted to be the
president has has talked for years about
this energy transition and the need to
support coal communities through it and
so it was it was twisted uh by by many
others and so we wanted to make sure
that there was some clarity
oh sorry um
you had mentioned just a minute ago
about
um not reading out any violence that are
scheduled
[Music]
is the United States opposed to having a
bilat with Vladimir Putin if
the president has been really clear he's
been asked if he's going to meet uh What
uh President Putin at G20 and he said he
that is not his intention city boy that
freaking grinder again the president
spoke to this he was asked multiple
times I've been asking multiple times
and basically repeated what the
president has said he isn't he has no
intention of meeting with President
Putin and then secondly
um president zielinski of Ukraine has
said that he won't come to the to the
summit um if Putin does has the United
States weighed in into that so we've
been very clear from this Podium very
clear about uh uh is that if Russia gets
to attend the G20 then so should Ukraine
uh it it would require members across
G20 to disinvite uh Russia and what I
can guarantee you is the United States
will show up and be be at the table and
we will be Unapologetic in our defense
of Ukraine and calling out Russia for
its Buddha War as we have been uh for
the past uh past several months but
again we've been very clear on how we
see that invite
doesn't come does the U.S still want
Ukraine to come
look it is that is up to president
zielinski and the G20 as I just said uh
that is something that the G20 would
have to uh would have to uh decide on
but we have been clear if Russia attends
then so should Ukraine
thanks um the president over the weekend
spoke with the German Chancellor Schultz
who was just recently in China to meet
with the Chinese president and I wonder
if you could tell us a little bit about
whether you were brief beforehand you
coordinated sort of the messaging of
what
you want out of this as you know
democracies in the big battle against
autocracies
um it seems like he weren't surprised by
shows going there and whether you think
that his trip was actually a success
when he got out of it
seems like he criticized Putin not
directly but warned against nuclear war
do you think that was a successful trip
again I'm we're just not going to go
into uh what a trip that one of our
allies uh undertakes like that is uh for
them to decide and for their own
reasoning to take these types of trips
we're certainly are not going to comment
about that from here the chancellor
spoke to it I spoke to it specifically
and directly and so I will leave leave
his words uh you know to answer that
question for him for themselves but we
are certainly not going to comment about
it read out to the president in their
call right look the it what he did it's
in our readout I just don't have
anything beyond to share from what you
guys have
more fun on Twitter and mosque um
is there any advancement of your
conversations on whether or not you
would actually pay for your accounts and
how does his comments today you know
impact that decision-making process
given that he's clearly pushing for it
so look I I'm I I don't have any
decisions or any policy changes to to
preview for you at this time uh don't
want to really really want to get into
hypotheticals at this time I think
there's still some decisions being made
from uh from uh from the company I'm
just not going to to get ahead of that
thanks Karina um the Chinese president
is planning a trip to Saudi Arabia
before the end of the year what is the
White House make of this trip at a time
when the U.S is reassessing its
relationship with Saudi Arabia again uh
not going to comment about that from
here uh we've been very clear about how
we are going to we're reviewing our
relationship with Saudi Arabia once we
have something to share uh certainly we
will do that the president wants to do
that that just make that decision in a
bipartisan way as you've heard him say
have you heard us say because this has
been a relationship that has been uh
that has been done in a bipartisan way
over the past 80 years so certainly not
going to change from uh from that
process but again I'm just not going to
get ahead of the president I'm not going
to comment on a potential trip or a
plausible trip from here that China's
going to have
foreign
do you have a reaction to the brothers
that have been going on for the few
um for the few weeks if you have uh any
videos of any conversation between the
administration and the government in
Peru and there is a wireless mission
that is arriving to the country on
November the 20th what do you expect
from from this nation so look we
continue to closely monitor uh what
we're seeing in Peru in particular the
protest of course we believe in freedoms
of expression and peaceful assembly are
fundamental in any democracy an
individual should be able to make their
voices heard in a peaceful Manner and
again this is something that we're
closely monitoring
thanks screen uh on the economy uh you
said here the president's plans are
going to lower costs they're going to
get inflation down but the president's
been giving us that message for more
than a year but basically without much
success so is it time for a pivot
so I disagree with that not having much
success because if you look at the
president's policies as it relates to
for example the gas prices uh the
president took bold actions as you've
heard us say you know he tapped into the
Strategic petroleum Reserve which is a
historic action and because of that and
it has been proven by data that that
action that he took has brought gas
prices down by a buck 25. and and that's
because he took action again that's
lowering costs during this really Global
challenge that we're currently seeing
with inflation every almost every
country across the globe is dealing with
these This Global challenge so that's an
action that he took inflation reduction
act again only Democrats Congressional
Democrats voted for that it's going to
lower the cost of energy is going to
lower health care premiums again action
that this president took to make sure
that we were dealing with issues that
really truly matter to the American
people we on understand that Americans
are feeling a little bit of a squeeze
right now and we get that the president
gets that from his from his uh growing
up personally and so the work is not
going to stop but if you talk about what
congressional Republicans if we are
having an honest conversation here and
talk about what Republicans are going to
do which is actually if they want to if
they want to repeal inflation reduction
act that is increasing inflation if they
want to get rid of Medicare and Social
Security
that's taking that's taking something
away from the American people that is
popular and that they need
Ed there's there's no end is going to in
the future at some point inflation is
going to come down we're still seeing
inflation at 8.2 percent near 40-year
highs
well we have seen actually that that is
that's not what we have seen from the
data the data has shown that we are
seeing some easing and inflation that is
what we have seen from the most recent
pieces of data and that is important to
note uh we're not saying that inflation
is not an issue for the American people
but if you look at the GDP if you look
at uh you know CPI if you look at the
data that we all look at all economists
take a take a really Keen Eye on these
pieces of information we are seeing
inflation easing now do we need to do
more work absolutely is the president
going to continue to do everything that
he can to uh to lower costs for the
American people yes
okay thank you you said that the
president is fighting for coal
communities
um but just a follow-up that doesn't
mean that he's fighting to keep these
coal mines open does it look the
president I I laid out very clearly
about how the president sees
um uh sees his his part in this uh and
what he has done uh you know he is he
has uh you know through the work of
working group on coal Empower plant
communities President Biden has already
delivered more than 23 billion dollars
to energy communities across the country
he has put forward plans that are
bringing new energy and manufacturing
jobs to States like West Virginia to
States like Pennsylvania and he has
secured critical investment through the
inflation reduction act to support coal
communities as well which he believes is
incredibly important which is why it was
included in an inflation reduction act
and that's from funding for coal miners
suffering from respiratory challenges to
billions of dollars in loans to help
them seize new energy opportunities so
again you know I mentioned this I just
laid this out while we're trying to help
coal communities while we're trying to
do everything that we can to make sure
that uh they have the funding that they
need Republicans that very same same
policy same monies that I just laid out
inflation reduction act which is where
it's coming from Republicans want to
repeal that taking away the efforts that
we're trying to uh to provide for uh
coal communities
you're helping them as the market
through economic transition is moving
away from coal that doesn't sound like
you're
taking any deer regulatory efforts or
any steps to help the mines themselves
stay open is that correct look I've been
very clear the president's been very
clear on this I don't have anything more
to add again we believe what he was
trying to say was twisted and we've laid
that down very clearly you heard from my
statement you heard from what I just say
it said here today um
uh Marco Rubio the ranking member of the
Senate intelligence committee uh
criticized the administration by saying
quote by giving Tick-Tock influencers
the platform of white house visits and
creating content inviting the signaling
to the world he said his safe to use an
app that is beholden to Beijing this
comes after tick tock admitted that some
European data was accessed in China is
the president signaling to the American
public that Tick Tock is safe wait can
you say that one more time because that
was a lot sorry
um so that the gist of it is that Rubio
argues that by hosting some of these
Tick Tock influencers here at the White
House okay the president essentially
quote signaling to the world he believes
it is safe to use an app that is
beholden to Beijing my question is does
the president see it that way is he
signaling anything about this
application so just to be very mindful
here not going to comment on Tick Tock
while the committee on foreign
investment in the United States as you
all know review is ongoing to address
concerns posed by a posed by the app so
generally speaking the Biden
Administration is focused on the
challenge of certain countries right
which is including China as you just
mentioned to me seeking for leverage
digital Technologies and Americans data
in ways that present on that's presently
unacceptable and is not safe for our
national security is it gives it's at
risk puts our national security at risk
so look we're taking the steps that we
can to address this challenge for
example the President issued the first
ever Presidential Directive defining
additional National Security factors for
for this very said committee to consider
in line with the administration's
National Security priorities like
protecting Americans America's sensitive
sensitive data and last year the
President Biden put forward an executive
order to protect American sensitive data
from uh collection and utilization so we
will continue to look for other actions
to deal with this and and again I don't
want to get too far into it but I can
lay out what the president has done
he was ongoing why continue to invite
these folks to the White House to create
Tick Tock and I I never thought that I'd
be asking a question about
um I feel like you've asked me questions
before about Tick Tock of parents who
are looking you know at this seemingly
benign ab and then they're seeing
reports that because of the parent
company by dance which is Chinese owned
that there's a risk and then they see
that the president United States is
appearance and I hear I hear your
question as you know the president uses
different mediums to communicate
directly with uh with the American
people including young people we think
it's important to communicate directly
with them but we understand right we
understand
the issues that tick tock tick tock uh
presents itself with and so uh again we
we use different mediums I just laid out
what we're trying to do in our efforts
to deal with the issue that you just
laid out don't want to get too much into
it because it's in front of the
committee but we take this very
seriously hence the executive of order
that the president did and we will
continue to do that okay
last week a White House official told me
that the president and the White House
was evaluating next steps regarding the
architect of the Capitol who is actually
a holdover trump Administration
appointee who serves a 10-year term I
believe it is there was an IG report
that said that he was misusing allegedly
misusing government vehicles may have
been
misrepresenting himself as a police
officer in Virginia is there any update
from the White House Beyond evaluating
the next steps regarding Mr blandy's
status yes so we take the IG report uh
seriously and the request from members
of Congress seriously as well and are
evaluating next steps and so that's what
we're currently looking at at this time
we don't have more at this moment to
share but we will certainly share any
updates that may come up when we have
them
nice great uh two questions if I cook
one um you and President Biden last week
we've been warning the American people
that uh election results may not be
official on Tuesday night that it might
take some time
um I wondered if the White House would
support essentially having States uh who
don't count ballots early uh or who
don't count early ballots so that
they're ready for election day would you
support having those States change their
laws to count early votes so that
election results will come in sooner I I
don't have anything to share with you on
that about changing policies or changing
what states do uh what we're trying what
the president was trying to say is that
um you know it we are in a time uh in a
different time uh where in in modern
elections where more and more ballots
are being cast in early voting and by
mail as I mentioned and many states
don't start counting ballots uh until
after the polls close on November 8th so
we're just trying to communicate with
the American people let them know like
this is this process certainly has
changed again in modern elections and so
again you know it's it was a it's an
important reminder for people to be
patient for people to understand that
and that's what we care about that's the
message that we're trying to put forward
to the American people and I'm just not
going to talk about policy changes or
what we recommend states to do or not do
your asses a couple weeks ago but the
World Cup starts in less than two weeks
and I wonder if there's any update on if
the Biden Administration is planning to
send a delegation or any officials to
attend that we don't have anything more
to read out from what I shared a couple
weeks ago on that okay thank you Karine
uh at a rally in Sioux City Iowa on
Thursday former president Donald Trump
said the radical Democrats are locking
up pro-life activists persecuting their
political opponents just what is your
White House response clearly that's not
true I'm not going to say more than that
it's just not true it's false it's a lie
it's not true so I'm going to move on
that pro-life activists are being
persecuted and in the meantime like
pro-life pregnancy centers are being
attacked it is just it that is just not
something that uh that I'm going to
comment from here about what the former
president said uh it is you know uh just
not going to get any further again I'm
just not going to get any further go
ahead
can I ask you to just flush out some of
the desired deliverables from these
upcoming Summits uh starting with clock
27 the call from developing nations for
100 billion dollars to address I believe
the term is loss and damage how far is
the U.S prepared to go on that and to
respond to that and then going looking
at asean in G20 the indo-pacific
economic framework is the US prepared to
welcome Canada or you know any other
deliverables for these Summit so I know
there's a lot of questions on this it's
happening in just a couple of days where
the president's going to leave on this
uh on this foreign trip we are going to
we're going we're working on getting
Jake Sullivan the National Security
advisor in the briefing room this week
where he will lay lay out the goals the
president has for this particular trip
not going to get ahead of of the
National Security advisor but we will
share more we'll have more to share go
ahead
Summit that's happening in December do
we have any news on that no I don't have
anything new on that as well okay okay
go ahead Brian oh oh Brian and Courtney
thank you all right
um I have a logistical question about
tomorrow election day and then I also
had a question about the chips act so
for election day what is what are the
president's plans is he going to be at
the White House watching returns can you
tell us more about what his plans are
for election day itself I just laid that
out didn't have it I don't have anything
more to to add uh we will share a little
bit more tomorrow when we uh when we
have more to share but uh he'll have a
robust uh pretty heavy schedule tomorrow
here at the White House as you know he's
going to this evening he's going to be
going to Maryland uh to speak directly
to Americans uh in in in uh at Bowie
States more specifically again not going
to get ahead of what we'll share
tomorrow but again after tomorrow you
all will hear from him
considering whether to do a big press
conference would he consider waiting
until the election results are more
clear nationally before having a press
conference do you guys want to want to
wait wait to talk to them
I was wondering if that's part of the
calculation as the White House I I again
I'm not I'm just not going to get ahead
of it I have laid out that what it's
been like in modern in modern elections
that it has taken some time for results
to come in because of by mail because of
early voting but not going to get ahead
of of that but you will hear from the
president on Wednesday and of course he
loves taking your questions and so that
will you'll hear from him on the chips
act
um
the
one of the companies that lobbied for
the ships Act is Intel they are have
announced they're going to have layoffs
this month and I'm wondering what the
president's reaction to that is as
companies prepare to apply for subsidies
from the chips act in the coming months
what's the president's reaction to when
it comes to the lobby for the jigs act
yeah so I heard I've seen those
reporting I think it came out a couple
of a couple of weeks ago if I if I
remember correctly I had not talked to
the president about this his reaction or
his thoughts and so we'd have to connect
with him and ask him are in the
companies that push for these subsidies
yeah I I you're asking me something that
I just have not talked to the president
about and once I do I promise to share
that okay Mr Willis in the back oh I'm
sorry Courtney thank you go ahead I
jumped ahead I apologize go ahead thanks
I wanted to ask what um the Senate
returns next week while you guys will be
out of
um can you talk a little bit about what
the president's priorities are going to
be in the weeks of the lame duck session
given that it's such a scrunched period
of time I I know this is a question that
people are
looking to have we're going to wait for
Congress to come back uh and to have
that discussion to have that
conversation I know you said they come
back next week we will hope the
president will certainly uh be on
foreign travel and we certainly are
going to be uh talking to them about the
lame duck period there's a lot that
needs to happen right before we get
there and so once we have a more of a
robust uh um kind of proposal what it is
that we see that see what the lame duck
is for us we'll certainly share that
so talk about the U.S presence on the
ground at the climate change conference
and the president will be there on
Friday
um you have a new climate advisor John
Modesta you have secretary Kerry I mean
what's the U.S presence on the ground
going to look like outside of the
President Biden we'll have more we'll
have more to share the NSC is going to
have a comprehensive schedule to share
in just a day or two with all of you as
we have uh we've done in the past just
to lay out what each day looks like to
lay out what each uh certainly in this
in this case Summit is going to look
like and including bilats you know just
give us another day or two and we will
be sharing that with all of you we'll
have a background calls as we've done in
the past and make sure that we are
providing all information to to uh to
folks here
again
President Biden made a pledge last night
during the New York rally to approve no
more drilling for oil but as you see
that as being in conflict with his
efforts to lower gas prices so no we
don't see that in Conflict look the
president was asked about new Drilling
in the Arctic and when the Trump
Administration opened the Arctic refuge
for drilling not a single Major Oil
Company actually bid on the sale and so
there is no shortage of opportunity for
these companies to produce oil here in
the United States they're sitting on
nine thousand you've heard us talk about
this nine thousand unused but approved
drilling permits
he said last Thursday in New Mexico the
oil companies quote should be drilling
more and that if they were drilling more
we would have more relief at the pump so
does he see that statement as being a
conflict with the Sunday statement
should they be drilling more or less for
a while so again oil companies are
sitting on 9 000 again 9 000 unused but
approved drilling permits they're
sitting on them and again there's no
shortage of opportunity for for
companies to produce oil here in the
United States 9 000 unused permits and
the president has been clear that rather
than using their record profits to pad
shareholders Pockets these companies
need to ramp up production and also
lower gas prices it is something that
the president believes that can be done
okay screen okay thanks everybody